the Joe Rogan experience I got super
into terror management theory recently
what's that um it's basically like the
guy that Becker Ernest Becker this is my
dad died a couple years ago and I hadn't
really had a lot of death and I started
kind of just I started getting into and
you called it - one time one day you
were like you're doing too much [ __ ]
you're doing too much stuff stop doing
so much stuff and I didn't realize like
when you have death and you're basically
terror management theory is this is
something you know of course but that
because we have a prefrontal cortex and
we're basically the only animal that can
ponder the future in the past like we
know we're gonna die and we can't
tolerate that anxiety it's too stressful
for us so we basically have to keep
ourselves busy and do meaningless [ __ ]
to feel important we have to win awards
we have to have titles we have to get
things in order to have a sense of
immortality right it's basically just
managing the anxiety of knowing that
we're rotting every day he's just dying
and could die at any moment it's just
like a false sense of control and
longevity there's a great book called
the worm in the hole
Solomon something Solomon I read this
book and it totally blew my mind because
I realized so many of my behaviors were
just about this fear of death because it
had been sort of right in front of me so
quickly
and his death was so freak that it just
it I had a really hard time coping with
the anxiety of death coming so suddenly
and so shockingly and like it [ __ ] me
up pretty bad but I started just making
myself busy with super irrelevant [ __ ]
in order to try to cope with that
anxiety and so I got super into terror
management theory terror management
theory terror like the trying to manage
the terror the daily terror then we know
we're gonna die about the book yeah but
it's awfully horror
that's what it's a less corny cover the
one that I have mmm but just a name
title TMT terror management theory
terror management theory is a little bit
controversial I think because it also
justifies some like supremacy thinking a
lot of I'm better than you and like
cultural superiority stuff I'd have to
what there's a guy named Solomon that
did it talk about it just because you
need so badly to feel important
that you start to sort of have the
delusion that you're better than other
people just because you feel so
insignificant because you know you're
gonna die you know we know we're a speck
of dust we know this is all ephemeral
and fleeting and that we don't matter so
we have to do things to feel like we
matter oh that makes sense we don't so
you sort of exercise your superiority
over people in order to shield yourself
from the futility of your existence yes
and to feel immortal and unite I mean to
procreate the idea of because we know
our mortality is so present in our
amygdala all day every day that I'm
better than you therefore I'm gonna
procreate more and we are going to
sustain and propagate so that we have a
sense of lasting yes that's why we want
to make a name for ourselves that's why
we want to get famous have the tangible
things stuff like that it drives it's an
anxiety that manifests in materialism
workaholism needing titles sort of [ __ ]
like that Wow that makes sense
so nasty evil people that subjugate all
their employees and yell at everybody
and like that's what they're doing no
they're gonna die Wow
yeah they know but they don't even it's
so deep in the subconscious they have no
awareness of why they're behaving the
way they behave it's well they've done
these studies were cuz I got super into
it cuz I didn't recognize my behavior I
felt like kinda the zombie I was like
trying to like set up all these TV shows
and I was like writing all these movies
and I was just like and I was like this
is so weird because my dad just died I
should know exactly what matters in life
which is none of this [ __ ] achievements
or money or any of that but I was super
into like I gotta buy this house and I
need to get you know this and this thing
and this watch and I was like this is so
not Who I am but it was me trying to
cope sort of with all of this anxiety
about death but they totally studies
where they put showed subjective video
and subliminal messaging put one frame
of just the word death imperceptible to
the actual eye and afterwards they
showed people pictures of woods or
cities and said where would you rather
be and you would normally go beautiful
woods nature and they always pick cities
because you just subconsciously felt
more scared and wanted to be in a place
that was safer [ __ ] like that
cities are safer than the woods I mean
just the idea of some protection and
right you know lots of civilization yeah
the woods are scary because we're on
some level know that we're only
superficially at the top of the food
chain
you know if we're out in the woods with
a bear and there's no guns or cages it's
we're gonna lose its like they do that
we just know how vulnerable we are
that's interesting because I would feel
like there's some anxiety attached to
the overpopulation aspect of cities sure
there's got to be some of that and the
cars and the noise noise we're not
designed for that right and the fight or
flight we're always in fight-or-flight
mode basically
[Applause]